historic day visa expectations they are
today's headlines in turkey's largest
newspapers the proposal by the EU
Commission to grant 79 million Turks
visa-free travel is a positive sign for
many in Ankara that their country is
finally moving closer to the block if
the visa requirements and things will be
far easier I can just draw up my plans
and buy a plane ticket right now we are
preparing lots of unnecessary documents
and this is a waste of time if you on my
opinion the recommendation by the
Commission to fast-track turkeys
visa-free bid comes as no surprise it is
part of an agreement with Anka has
struck back in March to help Europeans
deal with the migrant crisis turkey is
made impressive progress this is why we
are now in a position to put forward a
proposal which opens the way for the
european parliament and member states to
decide to lift visa requirements there
is no free ride here no free rides
meaning turkey has yet to meet some
crucial conditions they include European
standards on refugees data protection
and respect for human rights but many
have already questioned on kvass ability
to fulfill these goals in return Turkish
officials warned that if they are not
granted visa-free status they could pull
back on the refugee deal the European
Union might have different opinions on
some matters like meeting some of the
criteria but nobody should doubt our
sincerity on this matter we do anything
that we believe is right before the new
arrangement comes into place a clear
majority of member states and the
european parliament first have to
approve the deal instead of waiting in
line at the german embassy in Ankara
here turkish citizens will then be able
to access the EU for 90 days without a
visa and as early as july